hello everyone this is Amir from audio science
review uh we're going back to school again uh
this time on a topic that's becoming news around
my neck seems like every other day i do a review
somebody complains about me listening too loud or
testing speakers and and uh headphones too loud
and uh there's actually a lot to this topic and
much of it seems to be unknown given the fact that
many people get this wrong and this is not unique
to people in one camp or the other i find both
camps whether you're objectivism subjectivists
get all this wrong including reviewers and
and people claim to know the topic but in my
opinion clearly do not so i thought i'd make
a powerpoint presentation uh i was hoping that
once i left the corporate world i would never
touch powerpoint again here i am i don't know
how else to convey this topic and keep it in
some kind of organized fashion so here we
go i've called it music how loud is loud
let's start with what i call prosecutions
exhibit one and this actual comment somebody
made when i uh posted a review of the
hi-fi man Ananda a couple days ago and
uh he the literal comment was if you're listening
94 db you need to get your ears checked and
it's a shorthand notation to what people typically
say if you push them on where you get that number
they go to various workplace safety standards
as far as noise in u.s that's a part of the osha
government standards setting a body that's uh
sets uh limits for industrial noise exposure
that employ employers have to follow otherwise
it could be subject to litigation and and uh
fines and what have you and they usually go look
bring up this table this this individual did not
and then they point to various things in here
like i run a test at 114 db spl and they quickly
say oh you're going to go deaf in 15 minutes
and even at higher limits you know let's say
lower limits let's say 105 db spl um you know it
says oh only one hour clearly we don't listen to
music for just one hour we may listen seven
eight hours uh you know this this must be a
terrible thing um i should point out that the
94 db spl comes in my testing for headphones
in from my calibration of my headphone
texture headphone fixture i'll have a specific
instrument that generates a tone at 94 db very
accurately and you put it in the fixture and then
you measure the microphone voltage and you match
the two and that is what my fixtures calibrated as
therefore it's most accurate that that
that setting is probably almost as good
at other ones but i know for sure that 94
db is properly calibrated as far as spl
um and then that gets us to this graph i was just
talking about the 94 104 114 where did these three
numbers come from 94 i just explained which is
my uh reference uh test for frequency response
i also picked this because it's loud
enough that overrides the room noise where
i'm measuring headphone especially open back
headphones kind of letting room noise in there
and you want your signal to be substantially
30 to 40 db above the room noise so that when
you measure frequency response and distortion what
have you the error is well below one percent there
so i have 94 db and that's where that 94 comes
from there's no industry standard of you know
what you measure frequency response at so i have
to pick something um i have a nice situation that
i've used a topping a 90 headphone amplifier and
has three gain switches and each one of them is
separated by 10 db so all i've got to do to
measure 140b is just flip a switch and then
114 i flip the switch again and the key with
that is that i don't have to muck with the
volume control and lose my setting so i just flip
a switch three different ways and capture three
settings and like this uh abyss Diana
v2 headphone you can see that there's
three levels of of uh measurements to be made i'm
just showing you the uh the distortion graph in
here people immediately zoom into what is 114
and say why the heck are you measuring at 114
i never ever listen to 114. heck i don't listen
at 104 or even 94. i listen at 70 db 75 maybe
80 db none of this matters to me so this is all
bogus and you must not know what you're doing
well i think i know what i'm doing but let's
continue and let me demonstrate that to you
so how loud is loud um this is actually a
larger topic that's been researched a fair bit
into what kind of dynamic range do we need in
our systems to reproduce basically a live event
everybody's dream of hi-fi is that it replace
takes you you know as if you were listening to
a concert or or a live performance and you want
to bring that home right that is the ultimate
vision of what a hi-fi system should do so luis uh
fielder that uh worked at dolby he's an aes fellow
uh he was also a president of audio engineering
society for a few years i wrote a couple of very
intensively research papers uh their peer
review their part of the journal of audio
engineering society not to be confused with
the conference papers uh the journal papers
have to be really authoritative and and detailed
uh there's no automatic that is right but you know
you know it's gotta feel good to a bunch of other
uh peers of that person that this this brexit new
ground as far as information is sharing and he's
written at least two papers maybe three that
dig into this topic of how what is the the
two extremes that we need to represent in in
music what's the loudest that we want to
have what's the quietest we want to have
and once you have those two numbers that
differential tells you the dynamic range you need
and if you just and that gives you a db value if
you divide by six you'll get the number of bits
you need uh on this so it's a very useful thing
and dolby obviously is interested in this from
excuse me movie soundtracks and what
have you the paper is old as you can see
from the typeface so yeah this was probably 10
or 20 years ago 20 years ago maybe it came out
on this thing so he starts off with with going
back say all right what is what is the live
performance how loud is the live performance and
inside some of the early work that other people
had done not as exacting it as he's done and
uh very surprising information for example he's
you know there was the researcher by the name of
civilian and just two pianos uh playing the uh
spl was was peak svl was 103 to 104 db so those of
you who say ah less than 70 db it's like a piano
is not a drum it's it's what people think i mean
people actually listen to it know that it can get
quite loud but to a lay person you know thinks ah
the piano is nothing else you know it's not very
loud i can get very loud he also researched
a 15-piece orchestra that was 112 db spl
uh on this thing another study over here uh
they came up with numbers of 114 or 122 dv
for classical and popular music so you can
see there's some kind of consensus building up
these numbers are not in 70 80 db um then there
were some tests done in in recording studios
um and that was between 111 180 db spl and i
tell you i've been to uh major labels and and
uh but when they play uh in their mixing rooms and
master rooms they probably quite loud uh it's not
like what you think just background you know uh
music on this thing so um this was the following
of that same paragraph you know you
can see that it goes as high as 125 db
spls uh different recording locations now lewis
tried to actually set up his own test and there's
two versions of this this is the more extensive
one like i said there's another earlier paper
and uh that he found that the measures that he
measured as much as 122 db for classical 124
db spl uh for this electronically augmented
country music and i'll show you the the
second test that he did where that wasn't the
case so he went and surveyed 47 different uh
basically live presentations and this is not
him showing up standing in middle of the stage
and measuring he actually sits in the rows and
actually tells you row six or whatever that in
what theater is adding and uh oh concert hall he
said in and uh he he measured this using a special
peak detection uh spl meter which i'll talk
about uh later on and uh you can see the range
of numbers in here um rock music obviously you
know can get pretty loud uh 115 db to 129 db spl
but jazz music for example 127 db for jazz uh
so this is not some heavy metal rock and roll
you know music where people are just going deaf
in there you know it's what people think you know
sort of adult music and uh it's quite loud so he
has this histogram over here of all the different
uh venues and how many of them were at what
level and the ones in black are actually are uh
unamplified that means just the instruments
themselves producing sound so people think oh
yeah but massive pa speakers and arrays you
know you can you know crank that level to
anything you want and indeed those do capture the
highest levels over here electronic augmentation
but with no amplification you can see that we have
a number of the venues we want to easily land in
120 125 db spl in here so you know if you look at
down here he is nothing below 90 i mean it just
goes left over here a lot of these if you look
at the where the distribution is is between 105
115 db spl so uh quite loud again these are real
people listening in the real seating location uh
in a live venue of all different kinds of of
music and these are the levels that he found so
for sure you know forget about this
concept of oh i'm listening 70 80 db
i guarantee you you don't have a concept of
loudness or db when you say numbers like that um
he goes on then as i mentioned he defines the peak
and then he also defines the floor and some many
of you probably familiar with fletcher Munson
um equal contour uh hearing or loudness level
curves this is the lowest one in theirs called
the hearing threshold and it basically says that
if you take the frequency and you play a sine wave
uh the the lowest level sine wave that people can
hear follows this curve so it is not at all a
flat line that we think frequency response is
our hearing is pretty bad at 20 hertz it requires
65 db just to hear 20 hertz 65 decibels so when
you tell me you listen at 70 db that means you're
not ever hearing 20 hertz it's only 5 db above
threshold it just is nothing but the same 65
db here at 2 or 3 kilohertz is about 70 db
above your threshold or hearing so frequency
matters your hearing is extremely non-linear with
respect to this now know that when music screen
created a human being also sat there and evaluated
loudness with the same ears that you have so this
curve has been built into the music and it builds
into the your hearing as well so in a way it is
a flat perceived curve but in reality the the
hearing follows this kind of curve so when the
person is mixing mastering music he is creating
bass that goes way above 65 db uh for it to be
heard otherwise let's say it's at 50 db it's not
it's totally silent so he clearly is not going to
she's not going to clear music create music that
has you know you can't hear so turn it up listen
to it and therefore the base content which i'll
show you in a minute will definitely definitely be
a lot louder than it is in in in this range okay
so this is a good paper if you want to go find it
and basically he builds a case saying that look
you know the lowest level we want is around
zero below zero db and if the maximum is 122
db or 125 db we basically need about 21 bits of
dynamic range to have a silent noise floor and
be able to create a live music venues sound
level in our channel so anything below 21db
what we call flat pcm encoded is is going to have
noise floor that's audible or it can't get that
loud but that's fun of the topic and i've got an
article on that i'll reference later on for you
so so we've got this background of of what is real
what is the real db what is what are peak levels
and i'll talk about p versus average a little bit
later um so but what is all these noise standards
i mean clearly if if you're sitting there
listening to music uh there's no police there
showing up saying whoa all of these people listen
to this concert jazz concert or two piano is gonna
go deaf uh after an hour or two of that and and
why isn't there why isn't there articles and all
that saying hey any kind of live music is gonna
make you go deaf there isn't but i'll talk about
why there is and why they're completely different
domains people usually cite this osha standard
which i talked about a little bit bigger picture
over here and they have this graph and you can
see by 100 db is getting into this yellow range
and boom by 120 db is you know well into the red
zone first of all what is this number you look
at it in here it doesn't say db spl so dba the
a means is a weighted what is a weighted means it
means you capture the the sound in the environment
and you apply a filter to it a frequency response
shaping to it and you throw out a bunch of stuff
and what comes out is what you measure as one
number by the way not a sequence of numbers for
different frequencies but only a single number
so what does a weighting look like if you go to
Wikipedia uh you see that this light blue curve
is the a weighting so you take the let's say the
noise is out there it's uniform you know at 0 db
you run it through a software hardware that chops
off basically all the low frequencies look at
how much at 20 hertz is chopping up 50 decibels
and then at one kilohertz two kilohertz
three kilos it doesn't chop off anything
and then at high frequency starts to chop off
some of it again why does it do that because
remember this is inverse of our hearing what
i was showing in fletcher Munson curves and
fielders threshold of hearing it's
because they recognize that we don't hear
low frequencies that well so our hearing naturally
is a filter of of low frequencies it takes a ton
of low frequencies for us to be able to hear that
therefore why put significance on that one clearly
it's not going to be an audible thing it's not
going to be something that damages our hearing so
when my measurements are provided they're all
raw they're all db spls that means there's no
weighting applied to it uh you can't compare the
weighted versus unweighted measurements they're
completely different animals especially in low
frequencies as i mentioned so in here again 50
decibels is filtered out before the government
says you know this let's measure to see how bad
this is so this becomes quite important and i'll
show you that again if you look at my headphone
measurements you see this preference curve and
ignore this boost for now you can see that it's
sort of in blue it curves up and curves down
why because our hearing our ears and ear canals
are resonant chambers and they amplify certain
range of frequencies and they're most sensitive
in this sort of a two to five kilohertz or one to
five kilohertz down here sensitivity goes down and
you can see what a difference it makes it in that
it goes way down so you don't want loud sounds
in this region because the ear then amplifies it
again and subjects it to your hearing system and
you could damage the hair sales and and cause
nerve damage so you don't want to and this is
the area that's danger zones and that's what the
government cares about basically a waiting says
let's chop all this down way down here so loudness
in this area is not something that the government
cares about the safety standards care about they
care about myth frequencies they also don't care
about extreme highs as much but certainly
they don't care about the base frequencies
so that brings us to a major punchline
in that when we when music is created
it always follows this kind of this exponential
curve where all the energy is in the base most of
the energy is in the base and then gradually
declines to you get higher and higher now
on purpose i once picked an instrumental
track this chris jones has no sanctuary
this used to be the demo track it's very well
recorded uh 20 years ago it got overplayed
and doesn't get played anymore but uh going
and look it up on youtube or or if you have
subscription music you know look it up
it's a delightful track and and it's an
instrumental thing it's in strings it's a
male vocal so i didn't go pick some heavy
metal tracks or techno what have you picked an
instrumental sort of a adult music if you will
and you can look in here and say at 30 hertz the
relative level is 20 db below the maximum that
we could have zero db digital but then as you
go get to one kilohertz we're already down
40 decibels so if you you know the government
cares about how loud something is at one kilohertz
if you take that same loudness you're allowed to
have 40 db more in base so if the government says
hey 90 db is as high as i want you to go at one
kilohertz that means actually saying hey the base
can be 130 db and that's cool too so keep that
in mind that the energy and music is in this base
area it is not now you intuitively you should know
that you look at the driver sizes in your speakers
the woofer's giant and the twitter is little thing
right the woofer is moving in and out massively
the twitter you can't even see it move so it
should make sense that the energy and music is
in bass yet the safety standards don't care about
bass loudness they care about the mid to high
frequency loudness we actually care a lot about
bass because bass represents 30 percent of the
fidelity that uh consumers our listeners assigned
to the overall sound of the system so super
important to us but it's not super important to
the uh people who care about uh hearing protection
now this is a big confusion of difference
between peak and average loudness they're
completely different animal animals when
you look at music you know a drum gets hit
all sudden you get a spike and that spike is could
be just two or three milliseconds it doesn't last
a whole second doesn't last the whole hour doesn't
last 30 minutes now somebody going and working
the factory floor and there's a machine that's
cranking it just that noise floor is constant
listen to a washing machine at your house or or
the fan in addition in a microwave oven or what
have you those are constant levels of noise that
just continuously go on music is is impulsive
meaning that we have peaks and the peaks last
so little that there is no safety standards for
one millisecond of anything now i don't take
this extreme but i'm pretty sure if i played
one millisecond at 140 db you just do this and
be done your hair is not going to get you know
uh damaged in just that one millisecond uh on this
thing so now this also then let's talk about how
do you measure something like this the way you do
not measure it is by spl meter you cannot measure
it with spl meters integrate things over time and
they also have their own frequency response worst
thing is they go get a phone like this you don't
even know what the microphone frequency response
on this thing is how accurate any of that is
and the day rate they're way way way too slow
um as i mentioned in the fielder's research
he actually built his own peak detection
SPL meter and that's what he used to find those
numbers if you had gone into the same venue with
your phone and turned it on you'd get 10 or 20
db 30 db lower values because uh their peaks and
they have the lowest amounts are getting average
together and you just get you're not getting a
sense of what the peak amplitude is so you may
have thought you were in a music concert listen
to jazz music and it was 90 db but in reality
the peaks maybe in 110 120 on that okay um
the uh i've actually written a paper on on how you
determined uh what is wrong with an spl meter for
purposes of setting a dynamic range which
i talked about in in the research paper if
you're interested i'll put it i'll put this in the
description to to go and read it's a nice summary
of the paper and and talks about high resolution
audio and and the considerations there but anyway
there are ways to measure this uh but requires
fair bit of knowledge in what you're doing
and uh one of our kind members
uh goes by the name of soderdude
he actually runs a site called diy audio haven
and he has tons of headphone measurements and
good articles he's an electrical engineer
practicing one and he set out to actually measure
um the uh average to peak of of common music
he just grabbed a piece of music and i forget
uh was a Tracy chapman or some common you
know pop music track and he listened to it
at different levels and then took a 10 second
section of that music and quantifies what that
level is as far as loudness both subjectively and
as far as peak and average spls so he grabbed this
part of it and he was listening at what he called
comfortably loud uh that's to me that's that's
what i like you're enjoying it but you know
that your ears are not suffering there you're
turning it up you're enjoying the music you're
not listening to his background music while
you're doing other work you're enjoying it in that
he measured a 90 db average and a peak of 102 db
not 70 db not 80 db 102 decibels was comfortably
loud yet when i showed you the start of the
presentation somebody told me if i'm listening
to 90 40 i need to have my hearing checked this
is basically 90 db is listening and he's not
going deaf and he actually goes through when
when he gets uncomfortable i think it was like
112 or something is when he got uncomfortable
um and then he goes whereas faint on this thing so
absolutely you can't you know run by those numbers
you do i my first question when people tell me
you know that's too loud is how did you measure
your headphones how do you know how loud you're
listening to and the way you do that you measure
the voltages and in this case you use the storage
scope and the storage scope has these nice meters
where it captures the peak voltages in this case
is put in the cursor at the peak voltage that
it detected and then he's able to use that both
the peak and rms value is shown in near voltages
he then takes those and using the efficiency
of that headphone which uh tile had measured
the inner fidelity i think it was an hd 650
headphone and converted that to db and you know
tiles efficiency numbers you know is approximate
um but it's good enough for this kind of analysis
at least uh on this thing so a real practical
example great work done you can go in here and
check it out and uh he's one of the people when i
go in and correct people that this stuff's not too
loud he always kindly points out that that's the
case also um one of the interesting things that
at 94 db spl i can actually wear the headphone
on my ears and hear the sweep a bass is barely
loud on that the mid to highs get a little bit
uncomfortable but i can listen to it because
the sleep is like one and a half seconds it's
like which is done he actually won repeated that
exercising came back and reported said yep
you can listen you can listen 94 db and
you know you don't go deaf so now let's uh
you know skin this guy another direction thx
used to be a very big name in in
home theaters not as much of a
brand these days but back in the day it was and
thx has set up some certification levels for
how loud and how much dynamic range products need
to have their businesses home theater focused
and there for the speakers and amplifiers it
says that you have to be able to play an average
of 85 vv but have 20 db of headroom which means
that you need to be able to produce 105 db spl
and anything is thx certified needs to be able to
do this and you find basically commodity products
that are capable of having this certification
on them for the subwoofer which is what we care
about why i do a lot of my measurements in
low frequencies um actually these 115 db spl
is what is required to get the certification you
can have more but that's the minimum that they
require on this thing so that again proves that
we can tolerate the sub base a lot higher noway
would thx have a certification program that would
cause manufacturers to build a cope and accounts
people to go deaf right that liability for that
would be huge so clearly clearly p you know
there's they understand the topic and
there's a distinction between peak
of a 115 db versus an average of 85 db so
here they basically say you can have 30 db of
of dynamic range uh or peak headroom on this thing
now one of the key things key reasons are measure
at three different levels it isn't for frequency
response because you could just have one of them
but looking at distortion as a trend uh because a
lot of times we go in there and we want to boost
the low frequencies uh harman's research has shown
that preference that people have in headphones
is to not only have flat response they actually
have elevated bass and i find that in sub-bass
area it is essential to get a great sensation out
of headphones that you actually cannot get out of
speakers speakers give you a mechanical
feel which is wonderful but to have a
speaker or even with a sub that's flat to 20 hertz
it's extremely hard whereas with headphones hey
i could have a hundred dollar headphone that goes
flat to 20 hertz or even above flat at 20 hertz so
since we can't have that might as well get it
but what you don't want to do is have a ton
of distortion that goes with that or clipping or
crackling and what have you one of the tests i've
done slip it up work i don't always do it is that
i measure distortion pre-equalization and then
post equalization so here i did it with this focal
clear you can see the baseline is this blue line
here so that's just measuring itself and here you
can see there's only point five percent distortion
but the moment i equalize it just a few db notice
that it shoot if i don't allow headroom for now if
we ignore the vi 5-1 look at how much distortion
shoots up all of a sudden goes from half db
shoots up to 12 i mean half a percentage to 12
percentage uh distortion so how do you know that
this could happen well you look at if i go to the
uh first this is the kind of graph that tells you
that if you notice on here when i'm playing 94
the distortion is way down here but when i add 10
more db you know distortion jumps this much but
i had 10 more after that all sudden distortion
goes through the roof so you can predict how much
equalization you have to do whether you land from
infinity you go from this graph to to the red
one or you're gonna go into this green one
so a lot of times when i do headphone reviews when
i see this third curve is under control and i say
hey that's a good thing that means you can add a
lot of equalization and still not have noticeable
problems in there so continuing on um a lot of
the comments that i get is sort of personal in
that people trying to take a jab at me both from
point of view of oh i know more than you do and
oh wait a second you don't seem to know anything
why do you have to test these things this way
but step back say i see my
job in being the most critical
user of equipment there is and an analyzer of
equipment i need to be able to have stressful
enough measurements and listening tests where
i can separate even two excellent products
i don't want to say well there's a hundred
products that are all just as good as each other
what's the point of that i devi i devise both
listening tests and measurements where i can tease
out differences there in any product that you know
i come at it from different angles and i want to
find those uh cracks in there now 99 of you may
not push the thing as hard but the one percent
of you that do i want to be able to represent your
views as well last thing i want to do is recommend
the product and you come back and say hey wait
a second when i listen to my favorite music
i'm hearing this distortion you didn't
say anything about distortion in there
so all right well i need to then be able to
test that so when i'm listening to a headphone
i uh crank up the volume for like a second or two
and say hey what is happening to the bass can i
hear that distortion that i measure how audible
is that distortion i crank it up and i'm like
got really bad turning down or i crank it up i'm
like wow there's no distortion it sounds great so
my listening tests are designed for that kind
of thing i heavily value my hearings because
that's my job this is what i do right now it's
my hobby so please don't go make an astonished
remark that oh you know this guy is blowing his
eardrums and i'm not going to listen to him ever
he must be deaf by now no i you know i'm
able to beat many people in control blind
test because i do protect my hearing and i
i know the damage that this can cause maybe
you know 10 years from now i'll regret doing
this a little bit one or two second testing also
um but you know i do turn it up um when i'm
listening to music myself i'm not in testing mode
uh i listen to music six seven hours a day and
there i'm listening at background level music
while i'm working with my headphones and
then also now i land on the track in my uh
title subscription and i'm like hey that sounds
good crank it up yeah that sounds good you know
you're enjoying that and then turn it back down
and your ears will tell you that hey you know
it's getting too loud getting too annoying turn it
down so please separate out what i do for you all
versus what i do myself is it's quite insulting
to have people come back and say well you know you
must be so dumb to be listening at loud music all
the time that's not what i do um one key thing is
that it's very hard to know what these distortion
numbers mean so how audible is this uh what
i mean shows you the distortion from half a
percent up to 12 was it a terrible thing i have
to listen if i don't listen who's going to listen
you all going to want to go test that hypothesis
no it's my job to do that comparison so i turn
on the eq and i turn on the volume and say hey
you know did i hear any distortion or did i not if
i didn't well then eq is good if i hear distortion
then i'll pull the eq down even though from
tonality point of view i may have needed that much
space i said no that's just getting too distorted
or it's getting too bright i gotta pull that down
a great example came up tonight um oh this should
say e-like so let me fix it before i yep um
i've got a second example of this focal
elex and uh was listening to it and
i just was listening to the normal volume and
all of a sudden i hear the left speaker left
headphone cup starting to crackle a little bit and
i went up a little bit more and the right one did
and this is with eq turned on so bass has been
boosted and i'll tell you it just was not loud
music yes it was deep bass and yes i'd eq that it
was just normal in a good level of listening but
i thought well shoot if i just say that you're all
going to come back and say uh you know many people
have been saying the mighty you know [ __ ] out
clear or he likes doesn't do this and therefore
you must be listening at you know 20 to be higher
and then you go and death but i happen to have
my son here who's in his 20s and very sensitive
hearing much better than mine and i had him listen
and uh his report was the same his crackling
is clicking and to him the sound was not
loud no he wouldn't listen for hours and hours
at that level but he didn't at all think that
hey this is you know you're listening way too
loud before clicking happens so the crackling
was happening and uh it's a problem he said you
know and you know i've seen just a bare mention
of it in some reviews of of this uh series of
headphones from focal i think that's that's
not right we need to highlight these problems so
the company knows about it and even if they don't
acknowledge it i'm sure they read these things
eventually and the next generation will have these
problems result you know no headphone costing
nearly a thousand dollars should just crackle as
you turn up the volume on what i consider typical
audio file listening levels and the fact that you
can't hear it because you have the same headphone
means nothing i don't understand why people
keep saying well i've got one of these and i don't
hear i'm not great but i don't know if you have
the same headphone sample as i have i don't know
what music you listen to sure i don't know how
loud you're listening to because you don't know
how to measure it at all so telling me that you
don't hear it doesn't invalidate the fact that
i as a critical tester can hear it can validate
it and can stand behind this observation that
this is a fatal flaw in a near fatal flaw for
this whole series of headphones uh i would have
given these headphones highest marks possible
but you know when a headphone crackles
i don't care how good the tonality or
resolution is once you crackle you're out of the
running on that thing so it's not a headphone that
i would buy personally uh for that reason so i'm
hoping there's a focal version too or whatever
they decide to call it so long presentations let
me bring us to the end let me start with something
i didn't talk a lot about absolutely protect your
hearing nothing about this presentation is about
convincing you to listen louder you obviously
listen to whatever is enjoyable level for you
and that's fine and and indeed losing your hearing
is a terrible thing you can't get it back maybe
in the future there's some research that helps
us but with both age and loud exposure you can
damage your hearing so but please don't make up
empty arguments that shows that you don't you
haven't researched and i haven't understood the
topic whatsoever do not throw safety standards as
people for enjoying music safety standards have
waiting in them they're designed for continuous
obnoxious uh factory floor noise or machinery it
is not for music it's you never see those people
going giving tickets to the concert goers saying
you know or whoever owns a concert venue that
they're making people go deaf it just isn't the
same animal yes if you're dealing with pure noise
you know car engine noise what have you you
go by that but with respect to music it is
not in the same domain do not be fooled
with spl in one place and spl another um
in my opinion listening in moderation to loud
music is fine i mean uh when i go to a concert
this loud uh wear earplugs so i actually keep
my fingers in there if i don't have earplugs and
i try to stay in the back or something so i do
you know there are crazy you know situations
where you can damage your hearing but when i'm
listening to my system when i have volume control
you know beautiful well-recorded music comes
up it's got good bass good dynamics i turn
it up that's what being an audiophile is if
you're just listening to elevated music levels
that's not being audiophile you may be a music
lover but you're not an audiophile naughty fob
has gotten a great system with great dynamic
range great capability and wants to have
realistic presentation yeah crank it up uh on
this thing um know that with basically loudness
is when we talk about loudness it's essentially
how loud the bass can get without distortion
that is the name of the game that is what we're
after you know the perception on loudness for
your ears though is one two three kilohertz and
indeed a hundred decibels at 3 kilohertz you know
you go insane i mean i'll just your eardrums
will blow for money or come out the other
but 100 db at 20 hertz is 30 db above noise floor
above the threshold so it just uh doesn't it's not
an issue and please please don't keep saying
go save your hearing i know uh nothing i do
impacts my hearing you know this is this is what i
do and and uh um uh as the uh mythbusters used to
say i'm uh who you can call a professional so i i
know what i'm doing but really my practice is not
something that's different than than other people
okay uh hopefully this was uh useful to you and if
you weren't interested in the topic itself and for
me it'd be a great reference to be able to provide
to people next time they tell me i'm listening
to love okay uh see you in a future video bye-bye